the wave of violence in Egypt with
removal from power of President Morsi
and the removal from the streets of his
supporters brought em ep's back early
from the summer recess for an emergency
meeting the Foreign Affairs Committee
met behind closed doors but the message
after was clear condemnation of mostly
shift towards radical Islam of the
military's brutal crackdown on his
supporters and that the EU aid programs
should continue unabated in was the
right decision they have no weapon
exports for the moment to Egypt but the
program's of European Union should
support these people and should be used
to introduce again the roadmap demetriou
democracy as it was promised by the
present government the unstoppable
violence in Syria was also debated
uppermost the Assad regime's reported
use of chemical weapons last week
killing hundreds of people and the
possibility of a Western military
response the goal is not regime change
the goal is to punish for overcoming the
red lines and using chemical weapons a
trade route between Russia and Ukraine
has once again soured relations and drag
the EU in as well it's over the signing
of free trade and Association agreements
between the EU and Ukraine jus this
November which Russia sees as a threat
earlier this month it ramped up border
inspections of Ukrainian imports from
all sectors MEP s were told the
situation had eased on the borders but
Ukrainian opposition leaders invited
specially said there was much more to
Russia's position it's not a trade war
it's a jam political action and not just
against Ukraine it's a challenge that
two of us I mean the European Union and
Ukraine are facing right now